14 year ago i released movie film which
brought great shame to kazakhstan
but now i was instructed to return to
yankee land to carry out secret missions
i go to america
[Applause]
[Music]
what do you say no it's not me
people make recognize my face i would
need
disguises this man sex criminal
no no sex family
i will take this to be a fat like
american man
yeah this is a good one here where is
his crumb
what is problem officer you got somebody
that's strapped to the top of your car
he's in that passenger seat boss only
men and bears are allowed inside cars
i'm here to give my daughter as a gift
to someone close to the throne
i need dress with real sexy peels
uh this is a bag that just goes over the
dress
they're nice i really like this
let us present sandra jessica parker
drummond
i want this one with the baby on it
i have a baby inside me can you take it
though
no we cannot that's not what we do here
i feel bad
because i was the one who put the baby
in her
did you ever put one in your daughter no
i did not
where is everybody they want everybody
to quarantine so they don't spread this
virus
could i stay in your home
i hope quarantine never ends
what is more dangerous this virus
or the democrat democrats democrats
killing some of the virus no you can't
see the virus no it's still there
if you think you see a virus like that
this makes the virus
sleepy and then when it's sleeping
the daddy has a lot to learn my daddy is
the smartest person in the whole flood
world
and while the risk of coronavirus
remains low as the president said
yesterday
we're ready for enemy michael penis
i brought the girl for you borah
movie film you pissed me now if he's
still
all right what do you prefer you fist me
out life is still same time
fist each other
[Music]
you